la CGT parce que il y a quand même une
expression à laquelle elle réagit
d'isabeth Bank d'ailleurs la CGT veut
mettre l'économie à genoux est-ce que
c'est une expression que vous reprenez à
votre compte non pour le coup non moi je
m'en tiens ce qui a été dit dans
l'intersydicale on est parti prenant de
l'intersyndical on fait des communiquer
qui sont dosés au trébuchet et moi je
m'en tiens ce qui était dit mettre la
France à l'arrêt pour le 7 mars pourquoi
mais parce que il y a eu 5 mobilisations
quand même de grande ampleur qu'on
marquait quelque chose d'important dans
le mouvement social en France et on a
laissé trois semaines au gouvernement et
au président de la République pour
réagir moi je trouve que le mouvement il
est assez exemplaire tout le monde l'a
remarqué il est graduelle et pas en
trois semaines on a eu droit à quoi en
fait on a eu droit à deux déclarations
du président de la République une Rungis
et l'autre au salon de l'agriculture ou
pour tout dire il se fout quand même un
peu de nous il appelle au bon sens etc
mais enfin bon sens c'est pas sérieux il
fait comme s'il n'y avait pas eu un mois
et demi de mobilisation comme si les
arguments du gouvernement n'avaient pas
été totalement démonté par les experts
on a gagné la bataille de l'opinion
pourquoi on a gagné la bataille de
l'opinion parce qu'on a gagné la
bataille des arguments sur la pension
minimale sur la carrière longue
s'agissant de la situation faite aux
femmes dans le dispositif etc on a eu
raison surtout en fait et moi je pense
que le gouvernement en tout cas le
président de la République aurait pu
avoir un peu d'humilité il aurait pu
venir vers nous en disant bon écoutez il
se passe quelque chose comme il l'avait
dit d'ailleurs au mois d'avril 2021 si
vous en avez souvenir il a fait un très
beau discours à la sortie du covid
manuel Macron fait de très beaux
discours et donc et il nous disait j'ai
compris j'ai changé etc bah moi
j'aimerais bien qu'il reprenne un peu
l'esprit de ce discours de l'après covid
et qui disent ben voilà j'ai vu ce qui
se passe j'ai compris j'ai changé sur
l'économie à genoux vous dites vous
reprendrez pas cette expression mais
dans les faits est-ce que vous souhaitez
des blocages est-ce que vous souhaitez
des grèves reconductibles non l'appel
c'est pas un appel à la grève
reconductible mais c'est un appel à ce
que la journée de mobilisation du 7 mars
soit une journée marquante et y compris
bien entendu dans les arrêts de
production dans les manifestations
visibles du soutien au mouvement
ça peut être une fermeture temporaire
d'un commerce ça peut être différents
événements le long des cortèges etc
parce que la CGT annonce ce matin que
les expéditions de carburant sont
bloquées dans toutes les raffineries du
pays vous soutenez ça vous savez quand
un mouvement de grève est déclaré
moi-même dans mon organisation certains
de mes collègues sur le terrain vont
décider d'être dans une intersey
syndicale qui appelle à la grève et le
principe de la greffe c'est quand même
d'arrêter la production
[Musique]